حسنًا ، إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن
أرحب بالعودة إلى المستشارة ميركل في
البيت الأبيض حيث كانت
في المكتب البيضاوي عدة مرات ، لقد كانت
صديقة رائعة ،
وأنا أعتبرها صديقة شخصية وكذلك
صديقة رائعة للولايات المتحدة ، وقد
رأينا بعضنا البعض في  G7
ثم رأينا بعضنا البعض مرة أخرى في اجتماع
الناتو
واليوم نتحدث عن
مزيد من التقدم في العلاقات الألمانية القوية
التي
كانت قوية وتزداد قوة ،
لدينا جدول أعمال كامل
أمامنا سنجتمع
بمفردنا  لفترة من الوقت وبعد ذلك سنقوم
بإحضار
بعض الموظفين الرئيسيين لدينا
وأحد الأشياء التي أريد التحدث
عنها هي
الصداقة الدائمة التي كان
المستشار مسؤولاً للغاية عن
تسميرها
والتأكد من استمرارها ونحن
على استعداد
للغطس في التعاون بين
الولايات المتحدة وألمانيا كان
قويًا ونأمل أن نستمر في ذلك وأنا
واثق من أننا
سنشكرك على الرئيس
أوباما ،
سيكون لدينا متسع من الوقت
أجب عن أسئلتك في غضون لحظات قليلة ،
شكرًا لنذهب ،
شكرًا لك يا رفاق